today i specifically um
decided to show you some games that
um might make you
rethink chess just a little bit uh
it's like i don't know let me try to
explain it better so
these games each one of them had such a
huge impact in my career
mainly because it they were so hurtful
and it was like those type of games that
i
knew i was winning and i knew i could
have done better
or i wasn't at least losing and i was
playing higher rated so
there was like that stress of oh i'm
playing someone who's stronger than me
but i kind of couldn't really control
myself
or my opponent simply did much better
than i did
or for any reason it just didn't turn
out as it should have
and they kind of slipped away or i
chickened out one of those two however
you want to think about it
so it's made the these games quite
painful for me i've shown some painful
games before but
not in a nuts more than one at a time
because you know i i like my dignity
oh uh
let's see we can try
uh hello
hello hello hey i didn't mean to call
you
sorry you're good so got a call from
producer probably a
slip finger dial let's go for that i'm
good
well it's better than not um it's better
than receiving a call that you're off
air
those are the yeah
i'm gonna ignore that call
all right so uh getting calls from
producers is scary
if you are a streamer it's it usually
means that you're doing something wrong
or something's going around
or your wi-fi is dead or something is
dead basically
so yeah that's scary but besides the
producer
scaring me poor ben simon um
let's look at this let's look at some
scary games so i can personally scare
myself
so i have few um
yeah yeah so okay
so i have four games that i'm hoping to
get to
and um this might be a little bit of a
stretch because
the little bit of obs playfullying for
me
but also gmp she's not
here he's kind of staring at his
litter box which is kind of weird
anyways um so this was this
first game that's uh it was in
air flutes 2016 or 15. it was 2016 yeah
because i had my two i had just crossed
2400 like i played january
and february tournaments non-stop and
then i went to air food and this was
like yeah it was march 1st oh my god
almost
five years ago i feel so old
anyways i went to airflow and i got so
sick and i remember that's like
the first round i actually went to the
game this was the first one
i went to the game with like a box of
tissues
that i kind of finished middle of the
game and then i had asked one of my
friends to bring me another one so it
was like a very
uh memorable game
but it i played i've actually played it
decent and i had the chance to
get um will not lose let's go with that
but i blew it almost as well as i was
blowing my nose
yeah a lot of ouch just thinking about
it
anyways so um let's start the ah let's
start the game
and hopefully i can give you a little
bit more insight on
how to not play chess when you can't
breathe
yeah it was such a horrible the only
like however i did exams like that once
or twice history and geography
i don't recommend that you're sick you
should stay in bed you shouldn't go
flying around and taking exams all right
um oh well
thank you that's kind of good yeah i
guess
if uh my stream is better than poke
champs that's
sure why not i'm here to be entertaining
grateful i finished the whole box on the
second box i don't remember if i
finished it or not because
yeah so um if you've ever played in
airfloat open it's so strong they have
like different categories other category
a
b and c uh category a is for
uh people who have minimum rating of
25.50
i've never had 25.50 so i
played twice and i filled both times in
category b
and category b is for those who have
like higher than 2300
but i um
i did like um like the first time i
played i played really amazing i scored
like a bunch of different
norms and um i was not 2300 they made an
exception
because i was so young and talented and
stuff like that ah to be young in town
oh yeah yeah and the second time that i
played the next year in 2016
they um so i was like
that 24.01 crossed 2400 yeah i like i
played
and like i i let me tell you the first
two months of my 2016.
i played in switzerland for that i
played tournaments and so
actually hold on let's go back a little
i played qatar masters
end of december i flew to switzerland i
played
uh another basel open there which i have
another game of that here too
the last game i played the puzzle open
uh
it was like right after christmas and
then i played
a league tournament a league event in
switzerland because i was playing for
switzerland lake and we actually won the
whole thing
and then i flew to belgium
to play actually i think i came back to
iran for a week and then i flew to
belgium to play a
closed event and then from there i went
to serbia to play a closed event and
then from there
i went to austria to play league and
then from there i flew to moscow to play
air fluid open
so that was just the first two months of
my 2016.
so yeah you can already imagine how my
body was exhausted
before i even started this event i
should have cancelled it but
everything was already set and paid and
i was like yeah i'm just gonna go play
it was this was a sad don't do that
don't over exhaust yourself so
anyways um so in
this game we have gm pishi scrolling
around trying to
sniff my team uh in this game i really
liked it in the sense
don't deft the people cats
ah we got a cat jump coming up
come on cat jump so i can go back to my
viewers there we go
um so in this game i
uh my opponent was quite strong i
believe he was also um the gm
25 almost 50 yeah 25 43 okay
so um let's go ahead i'm a little tired
of talking
i just want to show some chests there we
go
so i'm a very big fan of this opening
but just trying to do
the queen's indian type and just getting
my bishops out
it's very safe if you're looking for a
stable up opponent
opening to play that's the way to go um
i play
i dabbled around with groomfield dutch
um
queen scam queens gambit king's indian
all the nimzo i mean i play
i just did everything basically and this
is my
favorite one it's so stable and solid
and
so however there's like a d4 missing
that's in order to be like the uh
queens in the end so the the idea with
this rook e1
is that i he wants to start pushing for
the center
but he doesn't want to like if he
started with d4 then i could do knight
e4 there is no more d3 to kick my knight
away
so that is why i started rookie one and
after rookie one if
i were to play knight e4 there could be
d3s there could be take first
and d3 so there would be a um there
would be a
uh what's it called like a the center
wouldn't be as
um obvious as
if the d4 was played it's more uncertain
to use with
e1 so one line that i really like to
play and i played
so so many different games is that this
thing with c6
uh one of my friends recommended it to
me years ago and i really did like it
and i played it so much and
i got sick of it so i had to change it
but
i think this is the the not exact
opening but
this is some of the games that i had
natalya and this is
quite similar to the game that we had in
us chess championships
um the round before last so it's kind of
interesting to see
full circle i didn't play c6 with talia
in us championships but i
have played c6 with her previously um
it's not exactly delayed semi-stuff it's
like one of those weird
sidelines that is supposed to transpose
to a main line but it never does but it
could always do it but they don't do it
so it's like a
funny thing um i was very into this c65
idea because i
liked this structure because
now after you play d4 my queen side is
so i have so many options in the queen
slide if i just can get like a bishop
a6 if i can get a knight to c6 this
bishop is super cool this knight is
super cool
but if i don't exchange if i don't get
this bishop to a6 then you are gonna
bring your bishop to this side
and then you would have an attack so i
have to be careful with my king side
because uh my king is a tiny bit naked
but your queen side is quite
uh pokeable let's go with that uh essan
i do know mitra
we are not in touch but i grew up
knowing her so
i'm glad she's doing well i thought she
was in france
uh anyways it's kind of a french
structure there we go yeah
but not exactly like my bishop still has
stuff to do
and your bishop is quite misplaced so
let's get this night out i know where
this knight wants to go
um knight e2 i think maybe bishop f1
this idea might have been
a little faster but knight e2
okay i have to try and get this bishop
out
here but since you didn't play bishop f1
then i'm not in a rush but i'm prepared
to do it
so i would want to try to play a5 but it
might be a little too early so i went
for knight a5
um knight f4 now let me ask you a little
question let's do a little evaluation
what's going on here do you want to be
white do you want to be black keep in
mind that i chose to enter
this opening so
exxon are you sure i thought facade was
in zurich and mitra was in france
i kind of like the white's position too
because
uh there is a pos potential for king
attack
if black manages to save it then black
has a pretty cool stuff going on in
queensland
so um black has to be played much
smarter than white that's the only
the reason i would want to be white
personally
but i like this opening because it has
so many different possibilities so
i'm good with that i can do that so
um here what move do you want to do as
black white just played knight f4 white
has been
trying to do the setup now what should
we do
yeah i agree yeah bishop a6 i've been
foreshadowing this bishop a6 for a while
now if whenever you want to play bishop
f1 i'm gonna be there to
play bishop basics uh in the game i
played queen c7 because
i thought if you play bishop f1 then i
can go
queen c2 and exchange the queens and
so i thought this would be a better way
to go if i can exchange coins and i can
actually try and do something in the
queen side
so my opponent was a grandmaster he was
pretty smart
so he tried to poke me back
basically but uh bishop a6 i think is
just as good as queen c7 bishop a6 is
something that i have to do anyway so i
might as well have just done it
um i wasn't sure what to do after bishop
d2
i thought if i go knight c4 then you can
still try to activate your pieces and i
wasn't completely sure about my knight
placement over here
so yeah um
that's why i kind of went for queen c7
but you see the game is my game is in
the queen side
now what should we do with this knight
should we come back or should we go
forward
it's kind of two options
yeah let's go let's try to go for um c4
because if you come back to c6 then
at this night this also doesn't really
have anything else to do like where else
am i trying to go so let's try to go to
c4
um at least try to like
bother this bishop so my opponent played
bishop f1
good choice wants to come over here and
take control
on the this uh
strong diagonal um i
ended up just going for a5 which was a
good idea i still
should try to do my best in the queen
side b5
queen d7 trying to poke around a little
and
now what do you think we should do now i
don't have this bishop a6 anymore which
is kind of why
i think i should have done that earlier
but
it's not the end of the world i don't it
would be better if
if this position would be actually
pretty good for black if these two
bishops were exchanged
that's why instead of trying to bring my
knight earlier
i should have brought the bishop earlier
but
um it's still i'm not losing here
white has advantage but it's not it's
still white still has to try really hard
so
how do you think we can activate some
other pieces
uh can f6 be played
or is it two weakening
uh right now i have six um little two
weakening especially because
bishop h3 and this pawn is to have
issues
this is not really desirable if this
if the e6 wasn't a problem then yes we
could do f6
but right now f6 should be like your
last
option
well why don't you try to activate this
bishop
at least when you play rook e2 because
you you either have to try
and uh go back and try to exchange stuff
or you have to do rookie too
and when you do rookie 2 then at least
this bishop d3 is delayed so it gives
you more time to deal with it yeah
i see a lot of people mentioning bishop
g4
bishop b4 now so good thank you um
yeah exquisite playing f6 is always a
rough one
so after rook e2 um
what we could do is
um well to be honest one of the things i
kind of do want to do
is figure out what to do in the queen
side
so what i think we should do can we push
any of these guys
should we just um
because i really want to try and get
this knight activated but i don't
really want to commit to g6 just yet
because
it's good to get the knight out but g6
feels a little premature
so long term black needs to figure out
what to do about bishop b7
that is true long term this bishop is um
in a pickle to put it gently
so in the game i went for h6 so whoops
i keep scrolling the wrong way and my
opponent immediately did h4
um it's a it's good like white's
actually
forming some really good piece activity
my piece and my piece activity here
looks good but it doesn't have any
merits like if my bishop
was on h7 yes i actually do really like
my position
it's doing some good stuff it's
controlling around i love it
or f5 or e4 if this bishop was in this
diagonal that my position would be
actually pretty
pretty dope but it's not so i have to be
very careful with that
um i here i felt like i was
very squished and i just wanted to try
and
um bring some some stuff for my king so
i went for rook c7 g6 is still a
suggestion but
white is clearly better here so after
rook c7
my opponents just tried to continue
free replacing the pieces to
start to really bug me honestly um
i should have most likely
sorry he should have most likely just
tried to go for something with drug c2
first
because this rook on e2 doesn't really
do anything so going for
c2 makes the makes it a little more uh
bothersome for me and now i have to
wonder uh what if knight goes to d3 what
if bishop goes to d3
it it makes my life hard my life harder
but with bishop h3 now i know all i
can't
do is touch this bun so i cannot touch
this pawn but i can do pretty much
everything else
so i kind of like that
uh yours you're right black is not in a
good position
but i managed to find something and give
myself some game
only to mess it up on the 40th move
um so after bishop h3
um i like white doesn't have any
immediate threat yes exxon good uh so
coin goes to e7
and my idea is 27 was just to well bug
you like
i don't want white to have an easy game
i want to bother white as much as
humanly possible
and i'm believe me i'm trying so
um after this why does it still
well i mean why does it still have so
that has advantage so white is using it
um but i want to ask you how do you
think white should continue because we
we can all agree that white's position
is better but how
how do we go about it
grades grateful nice um nice evaluation
yeah
white uh black does have a good knight
and bishop on c4 and b4
if i'd ever tries to um
if white ever tries to
remove it so you can just take yeah that
is true so that's good of a
good evaluation
um so
well fragrance i kind of like that but
what else how else can you prepare for
it
okay all right so i see some really nice
ideas of trying to move the king
trying to get the queen involved i don't
know if i
saw a knight h2 idea with knight h2 is
another great idea
one thing is that for sure this rook is
not
supposed to be here so if you could move
the stroke move this knight and get the
queen involved
that would be kind of the easiest way to
go honestly
yeah so try to get the queen involved
that's i i like
you guys are doing it by saying queen d3
but um
this might be a little bit more
sophisticated
way to go about it so
um now that we know what should whites
do
let's let's give it a try maybe um
so now whiteboard queen d3
now as black what do you think we should
do i agree this position
kind of sucks but what do you think how
would you play it if this was your game
hello peter
um the g6 idea
actually g6 um pretty decent idea
but you could try to uh make g6
like more worth it if you played like
bishop
to c8 as i did to try to like
protect e6 just a little bit and then
you could try to do this g6 so that at
least
you are holding a little bit of your
pawn structure together
so i went for bishop c8s just defending
this guy
just a little bit and my opponent went
knight h2 do we think
knight h2 is a good move because
lightish too like we're trying to go
with this knight no i'm not saying
knight is just not a good move
uh but i would like to see what you guys
think about knight h2
uh exquisite i agree there is not really
a breakthrough in the queen side and we
need
to uh kind of save on save our king
that's true
but white just made that inaccuracy
knight h2 is not an accurate move
blah uh white should have still done
this rook c2
and still try to bring this bishop back
because this bishop on h3
is not really helpful you should this
bishop belongs to
in this diagonal and as long as this
bishop is on h3
the attack is not as strong as it could
be so
knight h2 it looks good but it's not
really helping
white's position this bishop is pretty
kind like just as useless as this bishop
so opponents need an inaccuracy
what do you think we can do
uh there is a computer suggestion that
i'm not really a big fan
of so i'm just going to mention it but
we're naturally i don't really want to
uh do too much about it because it's not
really
it's not a really good suggestion i mean
it's a it's an interesting suggestion
but it's
quite unrealistic so i can't i kind of
don't really want to
do too much about this unrealistic moves
but
let's see
quite curious to know what you guys are
thinking about
besides how we got to this position
because this position is not exactly
ideal
i know i know it's painful for me to
watch you guys are getting some
entertainment yeah
i see the chat is kind of agreeing with
g5 as well yes
g5 is what the computer says but i
didn't
i it just doesn't i don't want to weaken
my own king yeah like knight gets to go
to g7 blah blah but
i don't it it's such a computer move
because let's say take
take knight goes to h5 then i actually
have to play f5
it's like it kind of makes sense but at
the same time it's too
weird for me to like commit to it i
don't i
yeah that's the thing fragrance i don't
think i would ever place like this in a
real game
unless that's like the only move if
that's the only move then yeah
i'll be able to find it but as long as
there's other moves i don't really i'm
not going to find these
anywho um this is actually this is the
best way that
that i could have played this game and
just gonna try to exchange as much as i
can like queen maybe goes to
f3 and then i can just do some weird
stuff like this
but you get the idea of why this is not
exactly um you know my first
human brain choice so
um i did not do this g5 f5
crazy stuff i played bishop d7
it's a normal move it doesn't really
help position as much as during harvest
my thought process was that if i get if
i need bishop e8 then i'm gonna be able
to do bishop e8
this yeah this was quite impossible to
find i agree this is a really rough one
to try and find
so after bishop going to d7
my opponents went
for knight g4 now what should we do
all right so i see some nice f5s rook c8
i wouldn't really go for
uh no g5 bb blaster that the chance of
the g5 there's knight h6
so i um i started to actually get really
um scared of my for my position and i
just went for king h8 you can get [ __ ]
doesn't really harm my position doesn't
really help it it's
it's a very sucky position i'm telling
you it's not it's not that great of a
position the the good thing about this
position is how i managed to
um almost get away with it
and so my opponent just went for knight
h5
normal stuff again the best idea would
be to do this rook c2 and bishop f1
but besides that knight h5 is actually
holding pretty solid advantage i went
for rook g8
trying to keep my stuff together
and bishop g2 i honestly didn't really
understand this bishop
i still don't because i mean your bishop
is supposed to
like it doesn't matter if your bishop is
around here
your bishop is kind of blinded by my
pieces
unless your bishop is in this diagonal
and bishop
g2 doesn't really get you to e4 so i'm
i'm really get it
yeah i'm trying to wiggle out like maybe
get my king off the board a little
have fun with it um so
quite funny um i went for queen f8
i'm kind of putting my pieces and for
chess 960 at this point
and he finally did this roxy too now
um i started to to
think about the iff5 idea but it's not
ready yet
so how can we try to get my
how can i try to get my f5 idea ready
so
bishop b7 yeah let's go careful we still
can't really do g6 and stuff because my
h6 is quite uh wonderful
wow so bishop e7 uh
he played bishop f3 he's kind of trying
to get the pieces together but
in a kind of a weirder way than he could
um i'm also trying to free my pieces so
i
my knight literally has no space to go
so
i'm setting for next game proxy 8 trying
to
get knight to go to c7 next i'm gonna
try and go for f5 but i need a little
bit more preparation
so opponent finally did this bishop d1
wants to try and get into this diagonal
now is it time to play f5
or can i do or do i need to do more
preparation
this is a supposedly trick question but
quite easy so all you have to do is tell
me
well actually think about what would
happen if your opponent plays
f5 right now
yeah bishop let's go for bishop e8
because i couldn't play f5 because
whoops knight g6
so i have to defend the square and next
move i'm gonna do f5
rookie two was a mista was a good idea
but it
i still got my f5 so
now let's let's do another evaluation
what do we think
am i still all right am i surviving this
is my opponent
just a little too good at this point
yeah i'm kind of surviving right
so um in the game i
uh he theophasand now
what should we take this back with
serious question because we can take it
to bishop or
pawn which one should we try
ah don't take with queen there is a
knight yeah let's take with pawn
so i'm gonna now ask you a diff another
question
so um
how much do you think white is better
like what do you think is this game is
like plus what
one of the trainings that i got um
was to actually actively try to say
how much is like opponents like what's
the what's the evaluation so what do you
think is the evaluation
pretty much justin yeah almost there
almost plus six yeah
so it's a it's a pretty uh pretty sad
situation for
for me i'm pretty much losing
almost almost there like all white has
to do is just kind of win me
which was kind of fun because he um i
almost got away
no it's like plus six or seven it's like
really bad so
what do you think is this a good idea
when white is plus
that much six seven is that is this a
good idea
or does this like is this winning or is
it still kind of
unclear because if
if it's winning then yeah you should go
for it but if it's just gonna bring
even more complications for um
for whites then white shouldn't do it
so if you think this is winning huh
well to make fair knight 36 isn't
winning we do have to take it and i did
but knight h6 is not the best move what
do you think is the best move
neither six still holds a pretty decent
amount of advantage
but the problem with it is that it
gives black chance to try and
activate his pieces as i did
not well taking is doable but it that is
not as necessary because now when we
take
um if take
well bishop d7 it could bring more
complications
knight e6 is a pretty good move but the
best move
for white is just bishop c to just give
me to check my threads
now i have to try and stop this so let's
say queen g7
now you can just take on e6 easy peasy
does that make sense
so now my opponent took on h6 i take
back
he took knight d5 attacking some of my
different pieces
and my queen obviously i went for queen
g7
he took i took and he took over here so
he managed to win these two pawns
but at the same time i got active
my position got active so yes
i have two less pawns but i'm not
getting mated anymore right away
so let me ask you what do you think is
the evaluation of this position now
i like the the engine what do you think
like how much do you think white is
better
remember previously before knight takes
h6 we said white was better
by like uh plus six so that's a lot of
pluses
it's plus two so white messed it up
white managed to win two pawns
so here's plus two but it's it was plus
six without those pawns
that's why whoops that's why i always
tell you how much peace activity matters
more than anything else more than
material right now
plus six and then he eats two pawn and
it
drops down to plus two right
so it makes that's that's that's that's
all the difference in the world
now in this position why as black
i'm trying i have i can try and actually
get something done with this position
uh i should have played bishop h5 first
i didn't i played queenish7
because i didn't want to deal with um
any threats on my like the queen stuff
happening
but i should have went through a
bishopvish file i chickened out a little
um so let's say i went for queen h7
and bishop f4 now what do you think we
should do
as black
kind of funny because right now i
actually have
a pretty good move
i'm kind of surprised nobody's saying
this i see a bishop h5 bishop israel is
the second best move but it doesn't work
and
it's not enough not quidditch we're not
enough
not enough
nope bishop g6 not enough
think bigger
you actually have a chance to equalize
right now
which i also missed so don't beat
yourself up but
so ideally right now we would want to
use this thing like it's so cool my
my pieces are actually active finally
after like 37
moves so yes
son bishop should take on b oops bishop
should take on b5
the idea is that i can't do this night
move because i lose my rook
so in order to be able to do this knight
we want to attack your bishop i'm going
to give up this bishop
and when you take it now i get my d5
and next move i'm going to take on f4
and now i'm attacking over here first of
all i took one of my pawns back
now my knight is super active and
uh well if you take i just take and we
are gonna end up
in this position which is most likely
just still i mean this is
still a very rough position to try and
handle for both sides
but it's compared this position to like
10 moves ago when i couldn't even
breathe in that position
so peace activity
i went for a bishop going i went for
bishop h5 and i attacked the rock
and he took c7 rook takes e6
is better but i understand why um
taking on c7 is more appealing you eat
more pawns here
and i mean this kind of makes more sense
not gonna lie
you get to eat over here you get to
probably eat there and then you're gonna
just push pawns and ta-da
um he took bishop c7 i took that guy
and took over here and here
this is mu 40 so for those of you
who don't know um
how air fluid open works one of the
oldest and strongest opens in the world
and it's so it's so cool
but at the same time so long um like at
like a lot of the super like
professional events
you get um
you get when you get to move
40 you get another half an hour added to
your clock and this
is a move 40. so my opponent did his
move 40 he got half an hour
and it's my turn to do and get my half
an hour
and i messed it up because i didn't have
any time on my clock to think
so yeah and i see you guys are
suggesting rook takes g3 but does rook
takes g3 really work
that was what i was trying to figure out
and i couldn't figure it out right on
time
and i didn't play it and
i lost the game in a matter of like less
than 10 moves
so yeah
all right so i say you guys are thinking
about rook g3 and thank you you're so we
are from that position with no move
under the effects of this that's pretty
cute i know right
um i um
so let's see rook takes g3 well you
gotta take it right
quintex g3 king h1 it's
i mean this is actually pretty nice
because i get to take over here and then
bring the rook
included too so most likely not gonna go
that route right
uh let's say you try to move the king
and
check i like this rook roller stuff
another check uh
another check um
something should go to d2 let's go with
the rook
king c4 or c3 i can just take over here
and ah let's check mate there we go
so um king going to h1 doesn't work you
don't need to calculate it kingish one
just doesn't work
uh but kink f1 might work so i i
couldn't find what to do after king f1
so now that we have time let's sit here
and think
what should we do after king f1
how do you play a passing move in a
position like this to just get
that's what i did so grateful that's
what i tried i tried to do a passing
move
just so i could have enough time so i
could actually think for next move
but this was my one and only chance to
get a draw and i missed it
so let's see where do you want to go now
i see a lot of queen fours i see some
queen d3s queen f4 is your only way
queen d3 uh-uh now opponent gets to
bring queen back
during bishop nope we need the king to
stay naked so queen f4
let's say king goes to e2
or e1 let's say go to e2 first now where
do we go after king d2
what do you think
yeah rook c3 it's so great yeah right i
didn't find rook c3 that was that's the
only
key move because if you don't do rook c3
you don't really have anything left
so i didn't find rook c3 and so i didn't
do it
and i lost the game um
so yeah that's kind of that was the sad
part about this game honestly
um so
let's see what else can i try to talk
about in this one
after rook c3 um i actually have some
serious threats going on
i also want to do queen edge 2 and push
your king back so let's say if you just
play h5 then i can just give you
check and
[Music]
when the king moves now i can just give
you check
check so
that's one way to go about it or queen
just g3 and then king d2
and then queen d3 and then check check
check
so what about if queen went to e1 here
what do you think would happen here
so that's the thing rook c3 here doesn't
necessarily
work you don't really need bruce d3
anymore because
it doesn't really have that that check
thread
as as strongly so what else
yeah rook g8 or you could take over here
too honestly
but rook g8 seems to be the stronger way
to go
and the only way that white can't stop
it
is rook a2 which i don't it's just blows
my mind
because now when you give check king
goes to e2
and you have to keep cutting the king
here which is
so so weird but i mean
why not fun stuff huh
yeah so um
it's just so it's just one of those
positions that
it's kind of always going to haunt me
because i always say cut the king
like drake's e3 rook g3 i always talk
about it but i
like in this position i just it really
caught me off guard
so that was the first game let me
actually show you how the game ended
i didn't do rook g3 i played rook f8
just because i didn't want to lose any
more pawns
and now queen e3 i missed my chance on
trying to take on g3 i got my 30 minute
but it's not it's i don't have i can't
find it
there's nothing else to find and he's
already like plus three
i tried to uh organize something
hopefully maybe try to poke a little but
it's quite impossible
to do so try to activate it a little but
my opponent already
is pretty winning and my position is sad
and i'm just kind of struggling to keep
all these pawns away and i
i just lost here yeah kind of a sad game
because
i thought i had such a great thing going
and yeah it just kind of fell apart
pretty
pretty fast yeah
so it wasn't one of my happiest games
but it was definitely quite educational
so what do you think about this did you
like it did you hate it i kind of hated
it honestly
but
it's very educational so i had to share
it i couldn't
not share it all right
um
i'm gonna give it a second for questions
yeah exquisite it's quite sad i can't i
mean i
i can't lie it was just it was such a
sad game for me
but um
i just really it's it's good to learn
from
i was very proud of it like i actually
managed to survive it way longer than i
probably should have so
yeah all right
i'm gonna move on to a slightly happier
game
so this game i was also black oh
hi jim i actually don't call him gmpg
off stream just on stream
um so
yeah in this game
uh this is this is the puzzle open
right yeah this is the puzzle open 2016
this is like right after qatar masters
and
right before uh like a month before
uh well actually like two months before
air food so that's that's a part of my
busy early 2016
that i told you guys about so it was
pretty interesting game
because i well i kind of really enjoyed
it
but i couldn't finish it up and that was
a very
um sad thing for me because i played it
so well
and right at the end i just chickened
out and you will see how i chickened out
it was a
just one of those um situations where
when you chicken out you really chicken
out badly
so let's go ahead and get
started ah clicked on the wrong thing
so um i uh
i believe my opponent was from
litwani or latvia
one of those two i think it was latvia
if somebody want to check it let me know
that will be kind of fun too
um yeah i don't think gmp chicken help i
mean actually he's going to be able to
help take away the sadness for
this um pretty horrifying games
yeah it was it was just sad game man
yeah i can't like at some points like
it's it gets really sad to uh
watch some of these games because i
like i spent so much energy and time
and trying to um he's latvian great
to try to like make it the position work
and
you you get right there and you you mess
it all up
so yeah we got that going for us too
it's a part of chess we have to kind of
deal with it
yeah i know he's being so cute
he's kind of i don't know if you guys
can see him well but he's like putting
his face against the wall it is super
duper cute
all right so i'm gonna uh go a little
faster because the opening didn't really
have
as the opening was a like i don't know
like it was a little weird
like there was nothing wrong with it but
i
um i didn't know how to
like my opponents knew much better on
how to play it
like i knew what i was doing clearly i
mean i i got into a pretty good position
but
my opponents knew better like i uh i
usually want to play this
um queens indian as i just showed you
right or
i want to play this nimzo in the end as
i would show you
but my opponent was trying to stop me
and
so i had to kind of i was kind of forced
into playing this d5 ideas
um so i got my night out
got them got the pieces out that i know
where they belong
now the other question is what to do
with this bishop what to do with this
bishop
i have no idea what is this a3 what do
you guys think here
black to move what on god's green earth
are we doing
uh great wolf i have no idea what that
means
i did scratch peachy on
it it was kind of nice
so like that's the thing i went for
bishop e7 and i just played it normal
but apparently i had a chance to play d4
what do you guys think does this d4 look
crazy or is this just kind of just cute
all right so what do you think
grade 12 i don't know how i missed that
story man we could all use engines in
our lipstick
ah there's a there's a way to get men to
wear lipstick
ah okay
uh it's so funny that people actually
think there's such cool technologies
available to
people just everywhere like i
i like i my ipad and my iphone are
background 2018
i haven't upgraded them like you think
i'm gonna spend money on a
little tiny robot to put on my lipstick
you're cute
yeah um so yeah a lot of
a lot of interesting stuff going on
around the world
uh okay back to the chest of it this d4
looks interesting but i don't i don't
know it feels a little too early to
to try it because then i would have to
go for e5 pretty like
what if b4 then i would have to like
play e5 and then you could do like b5
and it could get a little messy
and i didn't really want to get messy
because this was like the
last round of the tournament and i was
really hoping to
finish it uh positive and
so i just went for um
i just went for like bishop e7 normal
stuff
he took i took he played d4 b6
trying to save my pawn bishop b5 okay
let's save my
knight all right let's keep saving this
bad boy actually good but this is a good
boy
this this became a really good boy in a
little bit castle castle
and now this position it's a very
typical position it's a little messy
it's a little complicated
you don't exactly know what where your
pieces belong you have a lot of
possibilities but you're not entirely
sure about it same for your opponent
what do you think we should do how are
you gonna try and make something work
from this position
okay i see some ideas of trying to get
bishop to d6
um not entirely
exchanging e5 now too too much
too much we need to lessen it we need to
lessen the crazy
knight taking an e5 now
it's so cute nobody's saying this
exquisite wants to kick this bishop with
a6 too early nope
so bishop d6 possible taking possible
all of these are possible but nobody is
thinking about the move that i i did
which makes me think my move was either
super cool or super
weird might be a to save a good point no
you're going on the wrong way you gotta
come try and maybe go the other way
knight e4 is premature i agree on that
nah you guys no no so what do you want
to do with your queen let's try to
figure that out too
because you got to try and figure out
what to do with your pieces queen
bishop brooke these pieces like these
three are fine everything else could be
improved
why not just take all you take then what
am i supposed to do with this guy just
go back to e8
i already had an eye we already saw a
game like that with my knight on e8 i
don't
i don't i can't do knight on e8s they
make me cry
i'm not another not exactly quincy so
why not queen d6
so let me tell you a little little story
story time with dorsa hashtag um
in our team here at slu
we have a like a running joke about how
um
like the uh the
are knights like to be in like e6
d6 or like e3 d3 so knights are not good
on f6 and c6 they're only good if
they are on uh
d6 like on those like third rank e or d
file those are kind of fun i don't know
who started it i remember
rambali had that saying and then we kind
of got
used to it i have no idea how
serious we are on it but we've been
trying on it for a while
seems to work this is before i joined
the team but i managed to uphold the
team values and i
did what i had to and i got this
position going and so it's it's a cool
thing you it's
i recommend it so let's try to get our
knight to come to e6
no grade 12 that's like that's like the
fun thing like knights are obviously
good when they're
working together and dealing with center
that's not the problem
uh the problem is that the knights
could be better if they are on
e and d file which is not exactly a true
thing
it's just by experience we've kind of
happened to
have a lot of fun with that
so
what do you think so queen d6 opponent
just played queen f3
now what should we do i can't exactly
follow up with my plan
i mean technically i could but that also
gives that
it's makes it a little um
a little i don't know what to do with my
bishop
did i yes i did play queen d6 but i went
for a queen e6 now because i wanted to
get my queen to being kind of involved
but at the same time
get my bishop to also be
around so i went for queen e6
and he went for queen e2 and then i did
bishop d6
and then i got knight e7 so the idea of
trying to get knight
d8 there is nothing exactly wrong with
it
but this was before i joined the team i
didn't know the values
and beliefs of the chess team here in
santos i apologize to my slow teammates
for not
upholding the beliefs on trying to get
the knight on e
or d6 i'm so sad about that
i let you guys down but
anyways um jokes aside 98 is kind of a
cool idea
trying to go knight to e6 but i didn't
exactly know where else to go after e6
and so i wanted to try and activate as
many pieces as possible
and see you're trying to do f5 boom i
block it if my knife was on e6 i
couldn't exactly block it
so yay yes yes i apologize now i know
better than to
not put the knights on e or
d6 or three ed36
i guess
so uh in the game opponent but knight to
f3 now what shall we do
to be fair these ideas with g4 would
have been kind of cooler
if it if i didn't have this free and
free pawn to eat
so my guess is he's trying to prepare
for these ideas
uh he could have probably played like
rook c1 chilled out a little but he went
for knight f3
nothing wrong with knight f3 but what do
you think we should do
uh
yeah uh fragrance yeah that's a very
common idea to try to do this knight c6
e7 then f5 ideas
uh trying to do a6 i kinda like it i
like kicking this guy
but i don't really want to give up this
or
or let me also ask you this knight's
going to
f3 what would white want to do if it was
white to move again what does white want
to do
because i see a lot of you are
suggesting moves that are
all right but they're not exactly the
best ideas
and i think the problem isn't that it's
not the best idea it's that you
don't think what does my opponent want
so what does your opponent want
exactly he wants to eat my queen wants
to do knight g5
g4 or bishop d3 and just poke this queen
so i have to stop it so let's go for h6
so we stop it
uh in the game he got a little nuts and
went g4
now is g4 a good idea or not
let me let me rephrase it is g4 nuts
or does it actually work
okay so g for nut nuts i can live with
that
now what do you think g4 wants
okay it works but why g4 wants f5 right
so i gotta save my queen
what should we do
i guess the most important question is
what can i take it
which you can easily answer no
because sorry bishop d7s
you can't really take it boom bishop d7
so white wants to play f5 so what should
i do
how can i save my queen
no no no no if you touch this then it's
like
now this is becoming a monster take
take g5 or
b4 ah not that no i don't want to give
my opponent permanent advantage
no bishop e5 i don't want to give my
good bishop it's a good bishop i don't
want to give it up
so what about rook c7 we said that we
can't play knight g4
because there is bishop going to d7 so
let's stop that
let's to let's do two birds with one
stone i actually don't want to hit birds
two targets with one shot i also don't
want to shoot anything
let's satisfy to ah let's just do two
things at once
open a new square to run away and i also
want to eat your pawn
so what do you think about that
oh two birds were peachy he actually did
catch a bird once
didn't kill it he killed the bird by
giving it a heart attack
didn't even touch the thing like
attacked it the bird just fell and
i tried to like massage it hard and i
was
quite unsuccessful it was actually a
very sad situation
but anyways pishi has never killed a
bird
intentionally or sex so
well i mean he intended to attack it
give it a heart attack so technically he
did
my little murderer
um king h1 why
where are you trying to go
oh
well zippo knight c6 we don't we we
did this whole thing to come to the
other side we don't want to go back
it doesn't make sense
um
[Music]
so
uh knight c6 was legally possible but it
doesn't help our situation because
i spent so much time trying to bring the
knight to this side knight c6 is not
really doesn't
that kind of like messes with the
harmony so that's why we don't want to
do that drug c7
opens queen i want to eat your pawn f5
let's get my queen back
in its crib i guess
now g5 g5 is a little too ambitious
white's position is not ready if the
queen was in a little more
ready position if there were more things
that he could attack he would actually
be a
doable thing but g5 is too early
but so was f5 and so was g4
so if from here white started to be a
little too hasty
like rook c1 would have made more sense
then you try to like poke it
it goes away and then you try to like
block it and it it's still kind of
preparing for that
uh ultimate g5 idea
so you still need a lot of preparation
uh because when g4 happens then rook c7
f5 and g5 too early i take you take
now question what should we do we have a
bunch of different things to eat
or poke at
so what should we do
all right so i got one word for c takes
d4 i can live with that
what about f5 can i eat on f5 and get
away with it
all right well the thing is that both of
them are possible i
in the game went for knight takes f5 um
knight they said five white has an only
move of bishop d3
and then i get cool knight e4 and
if queen goes to h5 then this is a
we're going to come back to it
momentarily if we were to take
here on d4 that's another thing that we
definitely could do
now the thing to kind of try and
be mindful of is that after
take well what if
uh bishop takes
now what do we do i maybe would like
rook c2
coin got a move and it's such a
complicated position
and i didn't want to give white that
satisfaction of this like
weird complicated position uh this is
probably
this is most likely what i would have
gone for
and the the nights are a little too
strong like this there's a lot of
different things is happening
i don't necessarily love this position
so i didn't want to give you another
opening
i thought maybe c4 could be useful later
so i didn't do that i took on f5 and
then i did knight e4
94 again another only move knight h6
does not work because you take it over
here
and queenish five
everything is kind of going to my king
it's a hurtful thing
so um
i did knight e4 queen h5 now quite
black to move what should we do
besides petting the cat but she's being
super cute
knight there's six now 936 does work um
kind of like only move because you can't
really take over here
actually why can't you take knight takes
g5 what do you think is wrong with
knight takes g5
yeah so what do you think is wrong with
knight takes g5
well the thing is that your f5 falls
either with drug
or with bishop and either one
white gets more activity and you're
gonna have a hard time trying to cover
your king up
so that's why knight h6 was the best one
and
black is still holding there's black's
position is completely playable
a little scary yes but it's not losing
now
white made a mistake and he played rook
to f4
now white um how can we use this mistake
i found the best move in my game well
they're like two moves that are equally
good
i found them in my game so what do you
think
we should do here and um
well basically why do you think rookie 4
is such a bad move
because if rook f4 wasn't played
white should take over here we take
bishop c4
trying to put more pressure on this i
would most likely take it over here
and probably like go for queen g4
and this is a pretty doable end game
nothing not much happening
uh e6 maybe knight takes over here is a
it's a doable end game
uh still pretty pretty cool because
there's so many pawns to eat and so many
things to poke but
it's doable that's the point um
but the way my opponents played he just
kind of handed me the game after rook at
four now
why do you think i'm saying rk4 is such
a bad move
exactly look at this bishops
okay we should never play f6 actually i
mean
the problem with f6 is that knight takes
e4 and when you take back
then there's like a bunch of checks
that's kind of the only problem with it
and then you would have to deal with a
bunch of
other type of checks it's not worth it
that's not a problem with it
um so
not f6
what about taking what's wrong with
taking that's a simple move
any suggestions
um no well
after take what should we do
it's a little complicated i agree it's
kind of warming up your brain isn't it
now i can just do queen h3 or just c4
and if take then you could try and take
over here
but i didn't want to over complicate the
position for me
so here i just took on d4 because i
wanted to open up over here
which c64 was the best move
this is actu this is one of my best
games ever but
not um it i couldn't get i couldn't win
it so i don't really show it as often
but it was a very great game yeah
so um and
anyways so uh
in the game he simply took back on e4
now
if there was bishop d4 now i have this
f6 because if you take it i don't
see remember what was wrong here with
playing f6
the problem was that when you take well
i couldn't really
take back because bishop c4 and i can't
really take over here because knight
takes d6
right but when after i take here
if you take with bishop now well first
of all i have rook c1 but even if not
that i have f6
why because if you take now i could take
here if you take on d6
oh sorry sorry rook c1 still doesn't
work
what am i talking about you can do
bishop e5 there we go
or you could simply take back if
check now you can take it that's the
difference oh
brain freeze for a minute and after take
you can just take over here
see now you have a bunch of pieces in
exchange for just a rook
it's totally worth it so um this rook f4
was prematurely done white should have
prepared better but i should have
dealt with one of those pieces here
because rook f4 just
gives me way too many possibilities
and i use them i actually managed to get
a pretty
better um position so i went
for after rook four i went for uh
take and my opponent just took on e4
all right we gotta take back and he
played bishop c4
because well the thing is if you take it
i will take back
now if you take it now i have f5 and
this guy is falling
so a lot of the white pieces are just up
in the air
and that's why it doesn't really work
for white
so now let's go back
to the game and
he went for bishop c4 now black to move
what should we do
keep keep keep the keep the flow of the
game going
um remember that's
why we are trying to do this we're
trying to
uh get the peace activity we're trying
to make sure that i'm not getting
checkmated that's another part
yeah after f5 if you took it was kind of
cool right so you kind of
plug cut the cord
cut unplug cut the tubes okay i'm using
medical terms i need to stop
but yeah that's why it wouldn't really
work
yes b5 thank you tyrell kick the bishop
after b5 um now
actually i'm gonna ask you guys again
how much do you think black is better
so last game you correctly identified
like white hat plus six
or white hat like plus two what about
now what's white well
how much is black better we can agree
that black is better right
just how much
plus five almost yeah black is better
almost
by five yep
uh it's kind of funny because now
white doesn't really have anything to do
if you take over here
big deal i'll just take it you take over
here
big deal i can just take it whichever
so this rukon c7 proved to be very
worthy
uh this bishop here proved to be quite
twerty same with this bishop same with
this queen see
how they're all kind of working together
uh so after bishop c4b5 my opponent kind
of tried to be as tricky as
humanly possible and he went for rook f6
now black to move what should we do rook
f6 is kind of a tricky move you have to
be very careful on how
you continue
um you have only one move that wins
everything else white gets away with it
nope hiv 5 is not it can you tell me
what is wrong with bishop e5
why bishop b5 doesn't work
this is so much fun for me everybody
thank you for making my knights ha
bishop e5 does not work why do you think
bishop v5 doesn't work
exactly rick takes h6 now when you
take back again check careful careful
everybody
and if bishop g7 well this really
doesn't work because you're going to get
checkmated soon my friend
can't move this pawn such a sad
checkmate
and if you just play kingish it's just a
draw white manages to get away with a
draw
so you have to be very careful every
single move
not to make that kind of mistakes so
this bishop is a very key star in my
king attack so let's get rid of it i
i took this um
i take b take c4 and he took the h6
because even if he takes back i can just
now
uh can i just take this now yeah i could
just take this now
and this will be pretty pleasant
um if he played well in the game he took
on h6
we kind of have to take it because we're
getting check mated now
knight goes to g4 so again
how should we continue as black keep in
mind
some stuff are happening on h6 we have
to be quite careful on this
what do you think we should do uh it's
not
just knight takes h6 that's scary this
bishop is also whoops not that one this
bishop is also kind of scary so
you have few options on how to defend
which one do you think is best one
uh king h7 doesn't really help there's
also queen takes h6
actually king h7 is a pretty bad idea
because
you get checkmated in two
be careful
c3 looks good exactly everybody c3 is
the best one
because when you take ah big deal i'll
just go away
eh big deal i'll just run away and now i
have richie a2 but the good thing is
that there is no bishop d force
there is no way for your bishop to come
in
to my attack
so c3 was a good idea after
i should have played the c3 and i should
have continued something like this
but i did it a little too late i started
with f6 because
i thought if you give check i can block
it if you take
i can run and i got myself into this
position which is
still pretty better but you have right
now you have only
one move that keeps the advantage so
what is your one move to keep the
advantage
well you guys think about that i need to
plug in
my ipad so i can read your lovely chats
ouch no breakage eight actually doesn't
work
the problem with drinking chain is this
check you would actually lose this now
because if you move boom
now you're losing
okay it doesn't work rook c5 thank you
rick c5 is the way to go
and um after rook c5
uh i really like this idea because after
rook c5
well you can't really do knight f5 so
your knight
is kind of kind of weird here now you
just have to take a move and like
go away with your queen now i get to
save my queen
and in the game he should have played
bishop takes d4
and i would have most likely just taken
over here and it would have just been
like i have a
full bishop up so it would be pretty
easy to win after
but he didn't do that and he just went
for knight takes c4
and i really wish i had done this c3
honestly
anyways i gave check you go away i
did drink h8 uh
i could have started with rook h8
you move the queen then check but it's
kind of the same thing
now let me actually ask you this is
pretty easy
pretty easily done black is super
winning it's like
minus eight um so
how do you think we can win this black
to move
you you just have to find the idea of
how to win it
and i was in time trouble and i didn't
find the idea
so all you have to do is find that
strategic idea of how to win
what do you think this is not a draw
that's why it's kind of goes for the
pile of oops
i messed up that's kind of the theme of
today
exactly yeah i actually went for queen
h3 simple idea i want to do queen f3
take take and i want to give you
checkmate with my strong
with my strong bishop i should have done
that but i didn't
that's that's kind of the whole point of
i missed this idea completely
and so in the game i started the drupe
g5
containing the drinkage eight and again
i should have done this queen h3
i didn't i went for
queen f5 and i messed it up
yep i kept thinking i needed to get my
bishop activated
but i completely forgot about i could
exchange the queen on f3 you're forced
to exchange the coin on f3
and if queen if i played queen h3 you're
you are forced to allow me to do that
because well i'm
sorry i'm giving you a checkmate so
you're kind of forced to defend that
checkmate let's say you go
queen to f2 now i can give you another
check and i'm forcing
for strike meeting you now
after queen history why not rook g1
um i could just
take that and i mean it
it works but i could just take that and
then just go to rook history
also um what about
if you go here why can't i just continue
with my same plan
you have to take it and now yes this is
not
as beautiful of a win as it was i'm
still giving you checkmate ideas you
mean you could take it
and maybe just try kenji one but this is
still winnable
um so yes
yeah i messed up i went for queen of
five and he took i took
she took i went to rook f2 and
um yeah i tried to continue for a little
bit
but it was a draw i mean it was really
hard this is kind of a
like i went from a super winning
position that all i had to do was find
the queen of streak when f3 win
to this and it was really quite hard to
win
um i tried for a little bit but there
was not really
that easy to do and we agreed on a draw
so yeah it was kind of a sad game for me
because i was really hopeful on it
and i tried so hard and i played such a
great game
early on and i've got such a good
opening
transition to middle game and then i got
such a good middle game transition
to well actually not transition just got
such a good middle game to just
maneuver around with my pieces and
attack and defuse his attack and
continue with my attack and all those
and
kind of bummed it the last minute
yeah um i did a little post on instagram
so for those of you who are joining from
my instagram thank you
i always like those i i'm not trying to
do more
um there to get more people to come here
too
i see a lot of some of you have joined
the link
uh what what's your time oh i have no
idea this game was like
five years ago and it makes me feel
so old because 2015 16
17 was my like really high on chess like
i was just
always flying around and yes she's a
super cute cat
he is gmp she um alright so we are gonna
switch to twitch uh if you don't follow
us on twitch do
it like now
and um we are going to switch to twitch
because i want to review your games so
send me your games on leeches
so when we um it's going to take me
about five to
probably just five minutes to switch to
switch to twitch
and uh please send me your chats
links um uh please send me your leeches
links of your game in chat on twitch
there you go that was a mouthful
and make sure to follow us subscribe us
uh yeah if you have any cool games
i would love to see it we so far there's
never been a time that i'm sitting there
and i'm like i got no games there's
always games
so please do that actually right now
this is a winning game because i have
rookies
4k 8 let's go if you move back quite
messed up here
should have went with king f4 and then
take here
my bad but yes uh
yes so twitch uh the switching to twitch
uh
it's just stl chess
let me also double check on that
um uh where is my switch to twitch
i should have a command for switch to
twitch
sounds fun um
yeah stl chess let's steal chess club
actually
so yes this is our twitch id please come
there
and send us your games um
give me about five minutes so i can
refill on t
uh give the cat a hug and i will see you
there
in uh shortly make sure to i see a lot
of you are following great already
so make sure to follow us and preferably
subscribe so i can brag about it how
many subscribers i get
on my time but besides that i will see
you
soon uh how do you get twitch
make sure to come on our channel on
st louis chess club open twitch look for
us
and